so giving the seemingly insurmountable
obstacles and cracking the autism in
ignem what drives scientists and doctors
around the world to work on such a
complex topic well first most of us most
of us I think certainly all of us
believe that the truth of the origins of
autism will be found in scientific
investigation so the truth will be found
in science second there is good evidence
that early detection of autism or ASD
and related conditions can benefit
outcomes third there is good evidence
that a better understanding of the
specific causes of autism will benefit
the medical management management of
that individual and forth given the
heterogeneity the extreme heterogeneity
involved individualized approaches may
be the way forward in treating autism
and fifth from the basic research
perspective to understand human
development namely cognition speech
behavior the attributes associated with
autism we need to pursue scientific
investigation on the right side of the
slide appears the cover story from
Canada's global mail newspaper the
article describes the discovery of the
role of copy number variations or CNVs
and autism which our laboratory
participated in and in particular in
this paper the identification of the
noroxin one gene to be involved in
autism in this family that is shown on
the right this type of excitement in the
public often occurs when there's a
scientific breakthrough that often
offers hope for for families it's
important to point out that ASD remains
a behaviorally defined spectrum
disorders so the diagnosis is based on
behavioral classifications however in
the past decade or so new technologies
have been developed that allow the study
of complex problems from the inside out
or the bottom up most notably for autism
the technologies that have had the most
impact arguably have been in the areas
of imaging and genomics and animal and
cell models returning to the tree
metaphor these technologies have allowed
us to see the trees within the forest in
exquisite detail in this vantage point
of two trees looking from the ground up
we can see how the tree branches
interact with each
other and their environment I would like
you to keep this image in the back of
your mind because in the next few slides
I will come to talk about the issue of
neurons and brain cells dendrites and
synapses that so-called branches and
twigs as I mentioned earlier and I think
you will immediately recognize that the
images of the trees and the neuronal
brain cells will be very very similar so
as mentioned autism remains a
behaviorally defined spectrum with no
effective drug based treatment for the
core symptoms of autism although great
heterogeneity exists the data from
structural and functional magnetic
resonance imaging or MRI techniques have
converged to suggest underlying
neuroanatomical a typical ities that
produce an inefficient brain system or
perhaps in some cases an over efficient
brain system when considering the
complex integrated processing going on
in the brain this slide I was put
together by my colleague Jason lurch
summarizing composite data from hundreds
of different brain imaging studies of
individuals with autism and controls
using different technologies and
different testing strategies to define
sub regions of the brain involved in
autism or aspects of it and I would
point out that actually much of the data
was probably generated by people who are
in this audience and participating in
the workshop today so i also just wanted
to show this because this is really
really cool image so as we go forward
we'll see areas of brain involved in
gray coming up are the cortex and the
cerebellum which have been generally
described to have a role in autism in
red the inferior frontal gyrus in red in
asd superior temporal gyrus and purple
here also involved in asd the cerebellum
coming in green and through testing and
autistic individuals and controls to be
involved in repetitive behaviors in red
the caudate nucleus also involved in
repetitive behaviors and coming in green
the thalamus which is an important relay
station in the brain associated with
many different roles also involved in
autism and finally the amygdala
in blue which seems to have a role in
the emotional processing attributed to a
contribution to the autism spectrum
disorder so these are still relatively
crude studies the imaging techniques are
getting better and better that even
allow us to look at single cells and
single molecules and as I'll talk about
a little bit later I think an important
advance will be to marry these
technologies with the genetics and other
advances al biet I'm biased because I'm
a geneticist and what I refer to as the
genetic and genomic enlightenment in
autism I would argue that the greatest
advances in cracking the autism enigma
have come through the study of families
chromosomes and DNA the first major
advance came in the 1970s by Professor
rudder and his colleagues who showed a
strong propensity for for monozygotic
twins who by definition have identical
genomes to be more often than not both
present on the autism spectrum this
so-called concordance of autism between
monozygotic twins drops off
significantly when looking at dizygotic
twins who share fifty percent of their
DNA or jeans while different studies
have found different levels of
concordance between identical twins the
message is always the same and that is
that genes are involved in autism as I
would discuss some of these genes are
now been identified and some of the
mutations a mutation is a genetic change
at least to a clinical outcome are
sometimes inherited well in other cases
they are new to that individual and the
technical term is a de novo mutation
what I find perhaps most interesting
from these studies is that in some
instances even though the identical twin
may be autistic sometimes they vary and
can be on opposite ends of the autism
spectrum one mildly affected and one
severely affected this observation tells
us that the sometimes that sometimes
non-genetic factors and perhaps even
randomness can be involved in the
process of developing autism a second
advance of genetics is that studies of
families with ASD siblings have shown a
higher coincidence of autism
than would be expected by chance the
latest work led by doctor doctor
Lonnie's wagon bomb in Edmonton here in
Canada and colleagues indicate that in
roughly eighteen percent a roughly
eighteen percent risk of autism and
second siblings of families with
firstborn ASD children and this is much
higher than the predicted one percent
general population level again providing
evidence that genes or genetics are
involved there work in that of others
has also shown that early identification
of autism through the study of families
can improve the outcomes arguing that
genetic diagnosis may have a very
important role to play in early
interventions the third major advance of
genetics using the technologies I will
show you on the next slide is that
specific deletions or duplications of
segments of DNA encompasses the
so-called copy number variants or seen
v's I mentioned earlier and that are
shown here in the second image and the
panel in the middle here on this slide
or specific sequence level mutations of
genes depicted on the body bottom image
have now implicated dozens and perhaps
even hundreds of genes to be involved in
susceptibility to developing autism so
we now have identified some of these
genes that were hypothesized to exist so
presented here are the three major
genomic technologies used to study DNA
not only in autism but in fact in every
genetic disorder the first is a very old
technology some 50 years old called
cytogenetics or carry typing where you
look at stained chromosomes look at the
growth gross morphology and here you can
count the pairs of chromosomes
chromosome 12 22 the so-called autosomes
and then the sex chromosomes the
chromosome x and y so this is the
karyotype of a male this is the
technique that's used to for example
test for trisomy 21 that's associated
with Down syndrome more recently in 2007
what we call our micro razor gene chips
were introduced that have over a million
spots of DNA on a glass coverslip the
size of a quarter and using this
technology which is a form of
nanotechnology
you can take DNA from an individual and
tested in a few hours to look for the
presence and absence of specific genetic
variants across the human genome this
approach really revolutionized the way
we do genetic studies it allows to look
at the whole genome and one experiment
relatively cost efficiently and the new
technology is going to really change
everything and it is changing everything
is what we call whole genome sequencing
using next-generation sequencing
technologies so using this approach we
can now capture all six billion chemical
basis of information in a single
experiment we don't have to test one
gene of the 23,000 30,000 at a time we
can capture the sequence in one
experiment and in my laboratory now we
can do this for a cost of about
twenty-five hundred dollars or so the
human genome project cost three billion
dollars to complete the first human
genome sequence which was of craig
Venter in 2007 costs about 70 million
dollars and now we're doing it for
twenty-five hundred dollars of genome we
expect it will be a thousand dollars of
genome and it comes into the cost range
of Cary typing microwaves it will become
a standard clinical diagnostic test and
it's quite likely that each of us will
have our genome sequence as a step in
personalized medicine so these are the
technologies we're dealing with and here
I have summarized research results
generated over the past 30 years that
reveal the proportion roughly twenty
percent of the genetic architecture that
is involved in autism so if you were to
take a hundred individuals with an
autism diagnosis off the street
consecutively and run these different
genetic technologies and also do kind of
detailed clinical examination you could
group roughly twenty percent of those
individuals to have a known genetic form
of autism and these include what we call
asd related syndromes occurring in about
ten percent of cases including fragile x
syndrome where we see autism in roughly
forty to fifty percent of cases tuberous
sclerosis phenylketonuria rett syndrome
and i'll talk about fragile x syndrome
and rett syndrome a little bit later so
please keep these in your mind and
there's over a hundred different
syndromes where actually autism is a
component in some cake
of the clinical presentation there's
also real rare chromosome abnormalities
detected by the carry typing method I
mentioned earlier more recently rare
copy number variants I'll come back to
in roughly five percent of cases
chromosome 16 p 1 1.2 I'll mention a
little bit earlier later in others and
now using the scene the DNA sequencing
technologies we can identify specific
gene mutations at the sequence level and
we've now identified perhaps a hundred
or so of these genes I won't have a lot
of time to talk about it but certainly
we have now identified perhaps twenty
percent or so of the genetic factors
involved in autism there's many
different other explanations including
combinations of genes acting together
the role of other genes interacting with
the environment I'll talk about at the
very end of my presentation and also a
type of genetic modification called
epigenetic which you read a lot about in
the newspaper which is the process of
modifying the DNA sequence based on
environmental cues and factors but the
message here is that we do know actually
some of the causes of autism by the
study of these other syndromes and on
some of the genes that have now been
identified so I think it's important to
show this slide to re-emphasize now that
some of the CNVs copy number variants in
genes that have been identified are
considered to be the cause of autism in
the individuals that carry them these
six DNA segments represent examples of
the most common DNA regions found to be
involved in autism in our canadian
population diagnostic tests for these
seen v's and genes are now used in
conjunction with standard clinical
assessment one of the complexities of
the genetic findings is the fact that
some of the same genes are or regions
affect our being a found associated with
other neurodevelopmental conditions such
as schizophrenia bipolar disorder ADHD
and intellectual disability this
observation is perhaps not entirely
surprising because individuals and
families with autism can exhibit these
other types of disorders and perhaps
we'll talk more about this in the
discussion I will discuss the four genes
or seen v's highlighted in red later
with the shank one
mentioned on my next slide so on this
slide is an example of what we call a
pedigree for generation family with
female shown it circles and males as
squares individuals colored in black
have autism and all of them carry a
familial or inherited deletion of one
copy of their shank one gene which is
typically present in two copies one from
mom one from dad and this is on an
autism chromosome 19 so it's not the sex
chromosomes not the X chromosome I'll
talk about that a bit later the index
case which is the first presenting clay
case in the clinic is shown with the
arrow and as soon as can be seen he
inherits the deletion of shank one from
his mother for those a geneticist in the
crowd you'll probably quickly recognize
that only the male's will carry the
shank one deletion have autism while the
females do not we don't know the reason
for this yet but it may be that females
have other factors such as gender
specific hormones that protect them from
the autism the deceased grandfather who
also curious the shank one deletion is
shown with a stifled box since he had
what is referred to as a broader autism
phenotype and this is a subclinical form
of autism so in this case we could
provide the explanation to this family
why the autism came about in their
situation and I should say that we
haven't seen this genetic change in well
over 10,000 control so we this type of
population and family based approach to
convince ourselves that the genetic
changes we're finding are in fact indeed
involved in autism